now as with all things with live  television the technology has crashed  so what we're going to do instead is go  with a show a show of hands instead are  we happy with that  so will you will you allow me to say who  i think has probably got more hands  thank you so if you think that rishi  sunak had a better show and as a result  would potentially make the better prime  minister of this country can you put  your hand up now ladies and gentlemen  please oh my goodness that looks to me  like an awful lot for mr sunak who would  prefer miss truss as the next prime  minister now  i i wasn't expecting that i have to say  but i think with just keeping your hands  up for miss tross while we should get  some more shots just to show people at  home it looks to me as though mr tsunak  convinced you far more than miss trust